all right we are still thinking out
circles because circles are beautiful
objects we're going to zoom in
specifically on a particular kind of
feature in relation to a circle and
those are tangents now I think everyone
has an idea in their head or a picture
in their mind of what a tangent looks
like but I think it's really helpful and
because you guys know I have an
obsession with names to think about why
tangents are called what they are
particularly in contrast to what a
secant is okay now really quickly just
roughly right if we draw ourselves a
tiny little circle right and if I asked
you to draw a tangent you'll probably
draw something like this whereas if I
asked you to draw a secant you could
draw something like this okay tangent
secant now because of the way it looks
it's tempting to define a tangent as a
line that intersects with this circle
how many times once and equally it's
equally tempting to define a secant as a
line which touches the circle twice
right one and two but as you'll discover
next year when we introduce this hugely
topic called calculus
there's definitions ice water okay four
circles and okay nowhere else it's a
it's a very unusual unuseful definition
because if I gave you a shape like this
you know what this kind of shape is what
what's that shape it's a parabola okay
parabolas have tangent and secant as
well now have a look at a line like this
this line intersects with the parabola
exactly once but would you call it
attention answer no because like it's
not doing the tangent T thing it may
intersect just once but it doesn't do it
in the right way you would probably want
something like this morning I think we'd
agree that's a tangent right so are you
one of these
that's okay I hope you got a good one
they're not awkward bit okay I in the
same way if you had a curve like this
for instance right so this is a parabola
of an x squared whatever right this is
probably this is a cubic curve here who
knows this right now have a look at
something like this line how many times
does that straight line intersect with
the curve twice here and here but I
would say that that's a tangent to the
curve it's a tangent to the curve here
does that make sense I mean it looks
like a tangent right
so therefore this idea of intersecting
once or twice doesn't doesn't cut it
it's not good enough it's not a
definition which expands are very
gracefully okay so there's better
definitions for them and they come from
what the words mean so in the word
tangent I just want you to underline its
prefix right this is um the same as the
word tangible right which means you can
touch something and that's what a
tangent is it's a line that just touches
it doesn't actually blow straight
through it just sort of Nestle's
alongside and just touches the curve
okay as opposed to a secant which again
if you highlight the you can see the end
of the word I don't know why they
spelled differently I don't know where
ones with an e and ones with an A that's
English for you right but you can see
the endings are the same it's the
perfect is that a different secret
excuse me is where will you get the same
word section right for example if you
have an intersection or if you've heard
of like a pregnant where we're giving
birth she might have a natural birth or
she might have a Caesar section right
section actually just means to cut so
you got a group of things and you you
put them into sections where you're
cutting that group into different parts
does that make sense
so tangibles about touching where as
sections and secrets are about cutting
and that makes sense of the of the the
picture right you can see oh this secret
it's not that it hits twice it's that it
cuts straight through the circle divides
into two portions right this line here
it divides the curve into two portions
right it cuts across so that's what
tangents and sequins are tangents are
the most important object are we going
to think about but they are very closely
related to secrets I'm gonna use that
quite a bit so let's start to prove some
properties okay you've got a circle i if
you've got a bigger and a smaller circle
on your page because you made one
absolutely smoother than the other put
the diagram about to do put on the
smaller one but if your diagrams are the
same size doesn't matter pick a point on
the outside of the circle anywhere you
like sometimes it's not inside the
circle okay if you pick a point outside
the circle and they want you to pick up
your ruler and I want you to draw a
tangent to the circle that starts at
your point and ends at the the beating
points so see how this tangent it just
goes on forever okay what do we call
this by the way there are three kinds of
things depending on whether they go
forever or where they stop this guy's a
line right when something's got a arm
you're like of course it's a line well
if something's got a start and an end
it's not called a line it starts with
anion does they don't know what that's
called
if it starts and it ends
that's called an interval and the
weirdest one of all if it has a starting
point but then it doesn't have an ending
point what we call that just that's a
rate very good we don't use these guys
very often okay grab a seat Didier okay
so what I'm saying is I want an interval
I don't want to Ray or a line I want any
interval that starts at your external
point let's call it P starts at paté and
it ends as soon as it collides with the
circle okay so draw a tangent from P to
the cycle can you do that use your ruler
when you've got your intersection point
call that guy a okay now once you've
done that you might notice there's
another tangent that also goes from P to
the circle that's different to the one
you just drew so see how I've got this
one off on the top of the circle
there's another one where would you draw
it can you measure it with your hands
where else could you pretend it yeah
it's sort of up down on this side right
and just like I do you also have a
second tangent you can draw so can you
draw that one as well
okay now all throughout looking at these
circle properties is that a dud oh yeah
that's not useful at all oh it's in
there actually yeah you're taking it
yeah you can take it all throughout this
topic has weave in thinner circles I've
tried to ask you when we try to prove a
property to use your intuition a little
bit so what you look at PA and PB look
at PA and PB how do they look like
they're related to each other maybe your
ruler can help you PA as compared to PB
go ahead a measure them and you should
find that they are exactly the same
length right huh that's interesting okay
PA and PB they're the same length okay
now how can we prove that this is the
case how can we prove that this is the
case I'm going to UM you can measure but
unfortunately measurement is not enough
from a mathematical proof if you
measured a million circles and these
lines you might be able to find that
it's like oh this consistently happens
so that would be enough for scientific
proof because that's repetition and
observation but mathematically we need
more than lots of examples we need logic
that actually deduces that okay
I'm gonna let you sort of put that to
one side have your brain ticking over
because to prove this we need another
property